[Music]
hey
you all right never been better
sure don't look at it i can't let you
[Music]
hey
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight i'm
i'm here to say goodbye to all of you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
money's money can't [ __ ] around wasting
your lives following us around like dogs
what crawled up your ass
donny wait up
don't do this you can still change your
mind
get over here man [ __ ] this band not
your crowd
not your noise do your own thing bastard
i'm gonna miss you something awful see
you in the next life friend
great
love it when you're mad gets my southern
blood pumping
get in or change my mom silver hat
hey shane get us in the air
here put this on and it stays on got it
abc's on the streets of watson sons of
[ __ ]
skull cracking out there that us
johnny's
drawing his attention away from the
tower
collateral damage part of the plan too
thompson chew it up
range of choir
taking over
everybody
[Music]
get the payload on the elevator arm it
let gravity do its thing explosion rocks
the foundation
tower crumbles chaos screaming credits
exit window's gonna be tight jacking in
[Music]
[Music]
rats [ __ ] naps mainframe's not your
playground murphy come on
evac announcement broadcast it across
all frequencies and let's get moving
sheesh who wrote this manifesto
really need me to answer that question
jesus johnny
you've gone off the deep end that's
coming from a chair jock
come on get ready
it cannot be
[Music]
be back in a second
[Music]
stay hidden
[Music]
[Music]
what
the demolotron we're good to blow
socket elite run for it
shoot the cables
[Music]
now done yet still need to feed this to
their subnet
[Music]
[ __ ] knew it this was never about
corporate colonialism
this was about your groupie output
wasn't it
no you wouldn't understand
loves me
[Applause]
we've got heavy casualty
go go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sweet icebreaker foreign right
just wonder if we know anyone who can
switch the subnet protocol
hilarious you gonna help or not
do spider spin webs it's time we caught
some flies
thanks murph now just for good measure
holy cyber cow we're on tv take a look
now to arasaka tower its evacuation
ongoing after an unidentified terrorist
organization
released a manifesto threatening
violence
the terrorists stating their desire to
quote unquote
topple a monument to corporate
colonialism
night city's mayor imbole ebunike has
issued a statement declaring that he
will
bring the full force of the law to bear
in response to any act of terrorism
going now to our reporter on the scene
at arasaka tower
hopefully he can shed some light on the
situation as events
now get out of there
they're moving up hit the roof quick
[ __ ] that's adam smasher
johnny
like the wind
smasher told you johnny boy
told you i'd bend you someday
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
let us try once more you associates
who are they how do you acquire fiscal
material
gonna give good cop over there a chance
to say
something come on
which terrorist organization do you
belong to
how did you acquire fissile material
hey crabs i know you
see jokes
hot damn done and
gone
my husband died in that tower
but there are fates worse than death
i didn't want him to die
why did you do this to bring an
end to the madness you wreak
[Music]
my
ugh
you